Auf dem Skihang sieht es schon nach totaler Harmonie aus.
30 Wintersportler aus Südkorea waren einer Einladung nach Nordkorea gefolgt,
um gemeinsam zu trainieren.
Zwei Tage lang wedelten die Sportler aus den beiden Ländern zusammen den Hang herunter.
Diese Skifahrerin war von dem Ausflug in den Norden begeistert.
"Ich bin überrascht, dass die nordkoreanischen Sportler so gute Trainingsbedingungen haben.
Sie haben wirklich sehr gut trainiert und
waren sehr freundlich zu zu uns.
Das hat wirklich Spaß gemacht und war wichtig für uns."
Vom 9. bis 25. Februar finden im südkoreanischen Pyeongchang die Olympischen Winterspiele statt.
Beide koreanischen Staaten hatten eine Teilnahme Nordkoreas an den Spielen vereinbart.
So wird es ein gemeinsames Eishockey-Damenteam geben.
Nordkoreanische Sportler werden außerdem im Eiskunst- und Eisschnelllauf
sowie im Skilanglauf und im Alpinski antreten.
Bei der Eröffnungszeremonie werden die Athleten beider Staaten
hinter der sogenannten Fahne der Vereinigung laufen.